hi this is Mario with Mario's math
tutoring coming to another math viewer
to help you boost your score in your
math class improve your understanding
and hopefully make learning math a lot
less stressful so we're going to talk
about in this video is how to find the
tangent line equation to a parabola
using the distance formula so you're
probably doing a problem like this
similar in your class and so I just want
to show you how this works
so you have a parabola here okay this
u-shaped graph and you want to find the
equation of the tangent line to the
parabola at a given point so that's the
point right there and what you want to
notice or pay attention to is that the
distance from the focus of the parabola
to the point where the tangent line
touches the parabola that distance is
going to be the same distance as from
the focus to the y-intercept
that the tangent line you know makes
with the y-axis so that's what we're
going to be making use of is that this
distance and this distance are the same
so I'll show you what I mean in this
example so here what we want to do is we
want to find the equation of the tangent
line okay to this parabola x squared
equals negative 2y through the point
negative 4 negative 8 so I've drawn a
little sketch here for us just so we can
see it a little bit better and so what
we're going to do first thing is we're
going to find the focus so if you notice
this is in the form x squared equals 4p
Y and if you need to reference how to
graph parabolas you can I'll have a link
for the video for that but basically you
can see that for p equals negative 2 so
that means that p equals negative 1/2
right so if we go down here this is
going to be negative 1/2 right there
okay that's our focus so it focus is at
0 comma negative 1/2 and we want to find
the distance from that point to the
point where the tangent line just barely
touches the parabola okay and this point
over here is negative 4 negative 8 so
we're going to be doing is we're gonna
be doing the distance formula so let's
go ahead and do that so we have the
distance equals the square root of 0
minus negative 4 squared plus negative
1/2 minus negative 8 squared add those
together and take the square root so if
we simplify this we get
16-plus
this comes out to seven-and-a-half which
is 15 halves which if we square that we
get to 225 force and if we get common
denominators here this is 64 force plus
225 force is 289 force and if we take
the square root of that we're going to
get 17 over 2 which is 8 and 1/2 okay so
what that means that this distance here
is 8 and a half the distance from the
focus to the y-intercept okay that the
tangent line crosses the y axis over
here this distance is also going to be 8
and a half and because the focus is over
here 1/2 unit below the x-axis that's
going to mean that this y-intercept here
is going to be at 0 comma 8 okay now the
only thing we need to figure out now is
the slope of the tangent line we already
have the y-intercept and we'll be able
to write our equation so to find the
slope we use the slope formula okay
which is y2 minus y1 over x2 minus x1
and so we're just going to take 8 minus
negative 8 which is 16 over 0 minus
negative 4 which is 4 so you can see
we're getting a slope of 4 okay so with
me so far
we know the slope we know the
y-intercept so the equation of our
tangent line to the parabola at this
point negative 4 negative 8 is going to
be y equals 4x plus 8 and that's it so
again just a quick recap if you want to
find the tangent line to a parabola at a
given point just realize that the
distance from that point to the focus of
the parabola and the distance from the
focus to the y intercept that the
tangent line you know makes when it
crosses the y axis those two distances
are equal and you can use that to find
the equation of the tangent line so
hopefully you found this video helpful
go ahead and subscribe to the channel
check out some of my past videos and I
look forward to seeing you in the future
ones I'll talk to you soon